وللحديث عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
ابوظبي السيد سيد غنيم الخبير العسكريه
والاستاذ الزائر في الناتو الاكاديميه
العسكريه الملكيه في بروكسل اهلا بك سيد
غنيم بدايه مدللات هذه الزياره في مجال
المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه خاصه في ظل
عدم التوافق الامريكي ان صح التعبير على
حجم المساعدات المقدمه الى كييف الذي
ترتفع فيه الاصوات اليوم
اهلا وسهلا بحضرتك ارى ان في لازم نظف
الاعتبار ثلاث ابعاد متزامنه في توقيت
الزياره البعد الاول وهو بعد عسكري وهو
كما ذكر تحقيق نجاحات
في الهجوم ما يطلق عليه لجوم مضاد
الاوكراني اذا ما قرر ما قام به الروس في
بدايه الحرب الهجوم على سته محاور مقارنه
بهجوم اوكرانيا على ثلاث محاور بعد اربع
اسابيع ابعد ثمان اسابيع عفوا تم انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من كييف ثم تلاها بعض
الانسحابات خلال نفس العام لما نقارن ما
حدث اوكرانيا برغم ان الهجوم المضاد
بمراحله ايا كانت حصل فيها شيء كبير جدا
من التعسر تلاه التقدم ببطء الا انها لم
ترتد بالعكس استمرت الهجوم مع نجاحات ولو
كانت صغيره اذا هذا هو البعد الاول وهو
البعد العسكري وهو تاييد لنجاحات
الاوكرانيه
ويعني يعني التاكيد على مواصله الدعم اما
البعد التاني البعد سياسي شديد الاهميه لا
يقل اهميه وهو اصرار او ما يعلنه
جلينسكي على اصراره على مكافحه الفساد
وتطبيق القيم الغربيه الاول عندما اقال
وزير الدفاع ارتباط وزير الدفاعه ارتباطا
بالفساد الذي تم ملاحظته او التحدث عنه
سواء في التجنيد الجنود وعدم موافقات
الصحيه او فيما يخص المتعهدين الذين
يحضرون الطعام مقاومه للفساد بشده وفي نفس
الوقت اعلن شيء مهم جدا انه لم لم يتخذ
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه الاوكرانيه وقال اذا
كنت تريدون ان تتموا الانتخابات فعلينا
بتمويلها بواسطه الدول الداعمه بمبلغ قدره
كذا كذا معناه انه لا يقفل البعد
الديمقراطي حتى اثناء حرب عسكريه قد لا
ينظر لهذا الامر اما البعد الثالث وهو
خطير للغايه وهو بعد رومانيا ان هذا في
صالح اوكرانيا تماما وصالح الدعم ان الضرب
الشيء الذي برغم انه ضرب عن بعد بالنيران
فقط وليس بالقوات الذي استهدف على مقربه
من رومانيا فهو يحس الغرب على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على الاستمرار في الدعم
هنا نجد اهميه زياره
عفوا
السؤال الثاني كان في هذا المجال حول هذه
المسيرات التي اعلنت اوكرانيا عن انها
سقطت داخل الحدود الرومانيه ورومانيا تنفي
وتقول انها على مقربه من الحدود هل لمثل
هذه الحوادث ارتدادات هل سيكون لها ردود
فعل خاصه نعلم ان رومانيا في حلف شمال
الاطلسي ام انه سيكون حادثا عرضيا كما حدث
في بولندا سابقا
هذا يؤكد ما نتحدث فيما حضرتك بمعنى تجد
ان ما هو لماذا لماذا يصر دول شرق اوروبا
تحديدا على الاستمرار او مطالبه بدعم
اوكرانيا لانها تحارب بدلا منها تحارب
عدوها الرئيسي بدلا منها منها بولندا منها
رومانيا منها المانيا شخصيا
ودور البحر الاسود بما فيها رومانيا بمعنى
لذلك لذلك هم يتجنبون قتال مباشر بين
دوليه وبين روسيا كدو في حلف الناتو اذا
افترضنا ان كانت اوكرانيا هي الصادقه في
هذه الروايه وان التواريخ بالفعل او درونز
اسقطت داخل الحدود الرومانيه فان
الرومانيه تنكر لسبب انها تريد ان تحافظ
على التماسك والصبر يقعدوا في حلف الناتو
لا تطلب التدخل ولا تطلب حتى الدفاع عنها
الموضوع حوالين هذه الدائره تماما الا انه
ما زال في اوكرانيا كما ذكرت اذا فلتمدوني
بالاسلحه وتستمروا الدعم الى ما لا نهايه
حيث استطيع ان احقق مه امي خاصه انني لم
اتوقف فقط تعصرت واتقدم ببيت ولم اتوقف
ولم اتراجع كل الشكر لك يا سيد سيد الخبير
العسكري والاستاذ الزائر في الناتو
الاكاديميه العسكريه الملكيه في بروكسل
كنت معنا من ابوظبي